In this presentation, we will learn how to make
Relatively well established
How to make the denominator a relative number
What do I mean by that, let's assume we have a break
Its position is relative, and the simplest fraction
I will think is 1 / square root of 2
To make this relatively relative, we have to
We re-represent this number in some way so it does not contain
Which is based on a non-proportional number
The first question you can ask is
Why should we care about this?
Why should we make the denominators relative?
We are not supposed to do this
But I think the reason is because this is found in many algebra lessons
And why do some professors ask you, because he is coming out?
The numbers are common
I also think, it was told to me
Before the invention of the calculator
People have discovered that it is easier to have a relative number in
Place
I do not know if this is true or not
The other reason is aesthetics
Some people do not like seeing
1 / square root of 2
I do not know either
As you know, if you want to know the size of the pie
I have to set the number relative
So, let's learn how to make the place relatively
If the method is simple, if we have a simple and non-relative number
In the sanctuary, like this, you can
To hit the numerator and denominator with this non-proportional number
Divided by the non-proportional number
Now it is clear that this is 1
Any number divided by the number or any number divided by the same
It will be produced 1
In fact, we do not change the number
But we change how to represent it
So how much is this?
The rugs will have 1 × square root for 2
The square root is equal to 2
The denominator will be the square root of 2 ×
Square root of 2
Well square root for 2 ×
It is equal to 2
By definition, this square equals 2
We have squared it
We hit him himself
The output was 2
And so we made the place relatively
We did not get rid of the root code, but we did
We put it in the rugs
Now we have a relative number in the square
You can say, I now have a square root for half
This is simple, probably longer
Justified to make
Relatively well established
Let's solve more examples
Suppose I have 6 / square root for 15
The first thing I will do is simplify
This root icon
To see
Square root of
15 is 3 × 5
Nothing here is a whole square
If, this is the simplest image you can get
As we have done here, let us strike
The square root of 15 / square root of 15
This will equal 7 × square root
For 15
I just hit the rugs
Divided by the square root of 15 x square root of 15
It is equal to 15
Again, we got a relative number in the denominator
Now this is a relative number
We got a radical number in rugs or in other words, we got
Non-proportional number in rugs
I did not change the number, but I changed
Represented
Now, let's move to a higher level
What will happen if I say that we have 12/2 -
Square root for 5?
So in this case, we have a two-edged equation
In the place
This equation contains a non-relative number
You can not follow that trick here
If you hit the square root of 5 divided by the square root of 5
I will get a non-relative number in the place
Let me show you this
To prove to you that this does not apply here
If this square root is hit for 5 / square root of 5
The rugs will become 12 x
Square root of 5
And we have to distribute the place
Becomes 2 × square root of 5 -
Square root of 5 x square root of 5, ie 5
As you see, in this case, the way we followed did not help us
Because the square root is 5, although this part has become
Relatively, ie, 5, but this part became relative
Ie 2 x square root for 5
If this is what you should not do if you have
A two - edged equation containing a non - relative number in
Place
What to do is use our skills when
Different squares
I'm going to write here on this side
We have learned for a long time
If we have a 2-square root for 5 we hit it
2 + square root of 5, to what will lead us to this?
You may remember now
If you do not realize this quickly, then for this
The same pattern (a - b) (a + b)
(a - b) (a + b)
As we have seen in a number of lessons previously
a ^ 2 - b ^ 2
This is a simple review
a ^ 2 means a × a
a × b means ab
-b × a means -ab
Then, - ab × a
-b ^ 2
We delete this and keep it to us
a ^ 2 - b ^ 2
If (2 - square root for 5) (2 + square root for 5)
Equals 2 ^ 2, ie 4
Let me write this way
Equals 2 ^ 2 - the square root of 5 ^ 2
It is equal to 5
If the whole equation is 4 - 5 or -1
.
If you know the advantage of different squares
Or analyzed squares to their causes, however
You want to call them, so you will be able to make
Relatively well established
Let us do this
Let me rewrite the issue
12/2 - square root of 5
In this case, you hit the numerator and
Place with 2 + square root for 5 divided by 2+
Square root of 5
Again, I multiply the number by 1
So I do not change the value of the number
All I change is to represent the number
If the numerator becomes 12
X 2, ie 24
+12 x square root of 5
+12 × square root of 5, all this divided by
Again, this is like analysis
Box to the factors
Equals 2 ^ 2, ie is
Equal to this
Ie 4, -1, or we can - sorry
It's 2 ^ 2 - square root square for 5
If 4 - 5
Or we can write it -1
Or we can put 1 here and put
Negative signal in front of it
Hence, there is nothing that drives us to put 1 in
Place
We can say that this equals 24 - 12
Square root of 5
If in this case, we followed this method until we simplify
Not in order to make the number relative
This is what makes it look better
As you know, it is better to note this from the beginning
Because it was not clear
If you're me and you're trying to make a rocket, you've got it
On this answer and I got this answer, it will not be this
Obviously, at least for me, when I see him, I see it
Same number
But if we agree to make the denominators relative always
You'll, awesome ah
We got the same number
Now we are ready to send the missile to Mars
Let us solve another example
Suppose I have
Let's solve an example that contains variables
Suppose it is 5y / 2x
Square root of y - 5
If we follow the same method
We have a two-edged equation that contains a non-relative denominator
We must make it relatively
We do not know what the value of y
But y can take any value, hence it can be
Not relative
We do not want roots in the place
How much will it equal?
Well, let's hit the ridge and place
B 2 The square root of y + 5/2
y + 5 square root of
This is equal to 1
I did not change the number, but I did
Hit by 1
Let's start by then
How much will it cost?
The denominator will equalize this value box
Again, the box difference
Ie would be 2 × y ^ 2 square root of
- 5 ^ 2
If we analyze the factors, we get 2 square root of y + 5
× 2 square root of y - 5
This difference squares
And then the numerator is 2 square root for 5y × y
And equal to 10
These are y ^ 1, these
y ^ 1/2
We can write y the square root of y
10y square root of y
Or can be written as follows: y ^ 3/2 or ^ 1 1/2
However you wish
Finally, 5y × 5 = 25y
These can be simplified more
So how much will it equal?
We will have 2 ^ 2, ie 4
The square root of y ^ 2 = y
4y
And then 25
And rugs is - we can write this
We can keep it in the picture we wrote here
We can come out of common factor y
These are all possible images that we produce
But until we keep things simple, we can leave it
Let me put it differently
I can type it y ^ 1, and these
y ^ 1/2
It can also be written y ^ 3/2 if you want it
Or even y ^ 1 1/2
Or i can type it 10y × square root of y
All these pictures are equal
+ 25y
Anyway, I hope you have found it
Converting the place to a relative number